well hello reject nation it's Greg Alva
here John here so we're going to watch
the trailer for what I thought was a
real film that is apparently just a
special charity short film called Red
Nose Day actually oh boy but actually
before we actually go into this one we
want at least a children entrant Jamaica
for like at least a couple years people
have been saying when are you guys going
to have some t-shirts at least a couple
of years room consisting comments when
are you guys going to have some t-shirts
the only thing people talk to us about
only bigger only thing and now we have
some t-shirts beef has some shirt let's
take a look you could get all this stuff
at shop tops red shirt calm slash the
real rejects and you guys want to notice
like these pictures behind here that my
sister drew you can follow her on
Instagram at X Mary black X people love
her drives I even got a couple more
outside of my living room that people
really enjoy so let's take a look at
some of these so I got this on different
color variations of one that looks like
it's inspired by the poster of drive we
took some inspiration from our favorite
movies and we decided to make real
reject versions of those so if you the
Devil's Rejects we got that at the
Devil's Rejects one right there and this
is one my sister drew a long time ago
that was inspired by Ryan Wright and
cake that says the real rejects in
Spanish Zack stay wet my friend the case
alone right right to live on and of
course here's one that is my quote
nipple chills and here's there's another
one right here this one I call the super
bad one even though it's not super bad
but come on it looks like a super bad
type of thing so anyway you can go to
shops red shirt complex the real rejects
of course there's a link in the
description box and if you want to get
an autograph t-shirt from us go visit
our patreon where we have a bunch of
exclusive rewards over there and
exclusive video content there's a
specific tier that allows you to get an
autographed t-shirt directly from JA I
okay let's do that I don't want to go
into this right now let's play now one
of John's favorite movies is Love
Actually
seems to me that loved it everywhere
often it's not particularly dignified or
newsworthy it's always there if you look
for it I thought a sneaky feeling line
but Love Actually is we're all around
[Music]
yeah I don't mind oh well it's all of a
month things here we go again oh it's
the best sex you ever had
it's definitely one of the Kardashians
which one which one
[Music]
ah very attractive sir tonight
today oh yes thank you write that
confession in English now how many times
have I told you not to dance down
standards or to do love that Rowan
Atkinson character or whatever he's
called this is kind of a bummer that I
it's a bummer but it's also cool what
they're doing yeah because it's a bummer
and of course I don't want this to be a
real movie I loved the first one I
didn't really love it the first time I
saw it but as I got older
it's rather don't Mui mo Union yeah it's
definitely for mature audiences well we
thought when we were like 14 or
something in the theaters and it was
engaged wasn't aimed I mean I remember
us enjoying it fine but it just wasn't
welcomed and receptive to well they have
a lot of adults think even though
they'll be even the one with the little
kid and his mom died and stuff it's fall
in love with that one chick so looking
at this stuff I'm wondering how long is
this short film going to be because it's
still a wide range of characters were
catching up with here yeah I think I'd
have been more okay with that if I knew
it going in what I heard like Oh am I
gonna sequel and then I kind of later
that it was just this short yeah I don't
know I mean like they've done a lot of
fun stuff for Red Nose Day in the past
so yeah see I I don't know what to
expect out of this in a small format
it's funny to see how some of them are
still famous some of them are more
famous and some of them are not as
famous appear for Hugh Grant for example
camel love actually came out here and
was the biggest stars a be sad movie he
would be star of the film and he was the
biggest star at the time and you know
you got call of birth here Liam Neeson
who are both doing action movies now now
they're in her 50s
here's action billions kid was in like
Game of Thrones burrows yeah yeah he was
no sir
so Lee amis is going to teach his son
how to kill in this film finally that's
what I've always wanted a little boy to
grow forgotten how to do look about to
do is love I've had my heart broken and
now I hate ya what do I do
yeah and Hugh Grant he was in what was
that guy ritchie film Hugh Grant was in
a guy ran out of coal one to spy one
what oh great little man from my brother
from uncle who was you grin to the man
from uncle I don't remember the
character but he wasn't he was like like
a villain no no no he wasn't a villain
did you see this money what is the big
heal children cuz I saw the trailer I
just don't remember him at all to people
definitely in them henry cavill and
Armie Hammer who ever yeah a cute grin
he hasn't really done anything that's
been a hit in many years because I think
people are sick of got sick of the whole
charmingly befuddled character as funny
as seems like a cone first has been able
to make that that transition because he
was charming and befuddled for like a
minute there and and now you know you
know doing oversee a wider range of says
you know he seems to have been able to
diversify his career out cuz yeah I'm
wondering like where is he where is
Keira Knightley and Andrew Lincoln still
having this weird emotional affair I
thought they made that yet just shows up
with a cardboard aside and is rather
riding on it well then Heather here I
started to think to myself you know
maybe this is just going to be like a
punchline yeah for the purposes of a
short context of that movies and their
relationship is probably just going to
be over you know or only when they're
hanging out all together and because he
looks like Riddick and now we know
because your wasn't Rick Grimes and love
actually came out and now it rick has a
very specific look about them the hair
the beard and now we're gonna hear them
with a British accent in this in this
role because when you watch Love
Actually now it's more like oh [ __ ]
that's that's Andrew weakened yeah and
now you see it it's like that's Rick
Grimes Rick is in it
Bilbo is didn't it she was television
well there's famous now yeah yeah Audra
strange so here's his leg it's crazy to
see how they got a lot of them back to
get
Rowan Atkinson looks like he has an age
today it looks like the same exact age
to make I'll pull up a picture cuz he
they had a bit me her she has there's a
little wider and a little grayer yeah
but but he still was good like you don't
look ancient I don't know I was under
the impression that Bill Nighy passed
away yeah I didn't have I thought he did
so when I saw her I was like he's still
alive yes I have even yeah
that was a really funny bit about the
Kardashians but he's my favorite
character in Love Actually oh yeah he's
the most effortlessly enjoyable you know
be so reference he's so kind of anti
with them yeah self is I wonder if
because you know there's like drama to
be had in Love Actually
you know like Alan Rickman's character
Alan Rickman going to passed away from
Lomax what that said yeah I mean that
storyline is they said yeah that's a sad
story line and that doesn't look like
Emma Thompson's back and it's like
Martin Freeman's that guy's you know
torn cuff yeah this one couple I would
but you can't really bring back the porn
couple for an NBC special they're going
ahead and that's the thing well actually
was a pretty r-rated rough romantic
comedy film yeah they're putting this as
an NBC special so this is going to be
like the pg-13 version of it this is
more of a treat for fans I feel because
a lot of people have wanted to catch up
the date with it Hugh Grant still
dancing Leigh nice and still giving us
some love advice Colin Firth and I don't
know the actresses name they look like
they work things out for a welder's just
enjoying being together Keira Knightley
seems to have this emotional affair
going on and you're thinking it seems
that way I wonder how that works you
have like this up
I've never stood up to me as a romantic
element of the film
I probably member these three times and
to me I'm like I still think that's kind
of messed up actually actually uh yeah
yeah I mean it is it's yeah it's one of
those like muddy it's like a I think
it's a cool moment because it has you
know it's interesting yeah I get the
hard moment it's not it's one of the
most kind of heart-wrenching but we have
that movie especially like after but it
looks like you stole in love with her
after all the years like is like what if
I was married and then I found out
were pulling that crap with my wife I'd
hate you right away our friendship will
be done I hate you you know what I miss
Laura Linney more Lenny is here I worst
about Bruges rodrigo santoro ha he's
gotta be rodrigo santoro needs to be in
this movie
again I can't think he would be though
because she she blew her chance with him
well hey everyone else's man back and I
feel like rodrigo santoro will be so
cool to see in here you know after his
role in West world 300 and Jesus Christ
and Ben Hur I feel like in the left
standing well yeah as a fan of Love
Actually and I'm intrigued for this Red
Nosed it was Red Nose Day for co-opting
the symbol of the big red clown nose you
get to help child poverty to help fight
child poverty not to help bolster child
poverty because child poverty sucks it
does bad thing and I think that's what
the movie it is also promoting
total is Red Nose Day and I'm excited
that both a sequel and a remake are
going out of their way to sell friendos
they have totally totally what's going
on right now thanks Pennywise thanks
Pennywise hey why is actually in the end
of it this is actually I'll be so cool
the trailer is with all the kids grow up
into the second half of it when all the
kids are restless that would actually be
very very I would I would enjoy that too
visited it's like we're here for Love
Actually just to tell another story that
people let unrelated but also check it
out the evil that enables back alright
guys well hey thanks for tuning in you
can subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bill as we mentioned
we finally have t-shirts up get ready to
get annoyed because we're probably going
to mention a couple more videos at the
top that we have some t-shirts out go
check out our lives around for all the
exclusive goodies over there Jon's
reasons no nothing on him or on his debt
John Humpty Rashad Humphrey on Instagram
and Twitter he finally changed it to his
real name I know that rhyme about time
and and shout out to do all the children
who are suffering and and in the streets
of harsh times
enjoy your shout out that you can see
and hear one percent of every shirt
bought is going to support children that
I know doesn't matter like now say
something like that people will think
you're charitable
I'm Wow yeah it would be cool to have
like a cherry your mom would make it
would be in a real reject one of those
profit charities another one of the
charities for project